the mother of 12 year old archie
battersby has told sky news that she's
very disappointed after the supreme
court blocked her bid to stop doctors
withdrawing his treatment archie has
been in a coma since being found in
april with a ligature over his head his
mother believes he'd been taking part in
an online challenge doctors say archie
is brain stem dead and say continued
life support is not in his best
interests his family have been fighting
that decision through the courts and say
archie's treatment must continue
very disappointed in our system very let
down very disappointed
very disappointed on my son's behalf of
our system over here
is it what you expected
if i'm honest yeah i can't say no but i
did stay i would fight for the bitter
end with archie and as his mum that's
exactly what i've done and i hope i've
passed away for any other parents that
want to go up against um a trust
in this country and the justice system
it needs reforming dramatically needs
performing it's it's not right it's not
fair it's not right it's
how dare they discriminate really
against somebody that could potentially
have disabilities again nobody knows
what's gonna happen with archery
you know it's there's so many options in
other countries
why is it this country is so black and
white you know you've got a brain injury
that's it sorry
it's the end of the line for you other
countries offer so much hope and
so many different treatments
you had written to the secretary of
state for health
a letter
has he written back what did he say
um
i think that's it was all with the
lawyers it was sent sort of straight out
to the lawyers aaron pay anathar
and she's had quite a lot of input
i'd
do you feel this is the end of the road
legally speaking
legally i think we're exploring one
more option this evening but that really
is sort of the end
um yeah very uh
very disappointed really very
disappointed
and how are you coping because we know
that this morning you weren't feeling
very well yeah just a bit deflated
really i just wanted to spend the day
with arch today
um no sort of
i did an interview i think it was five
o'clock this morning so i hadn't had a
lot of sleep anyway
and we sort of
did shift work last night didn't we
lauren long fell asleep on archie's
um
yes i was just a bit tired this morning
really a bit drained but
i will continue to fight right until the
bitter end and then even down to now at
the hospital
because it's been hospitals away from
the word go just push push push we need
this done immediately you know it's got
to be a rapid speed we actually execute
this child and with the backing of the
legal system it's been very easy for the
hospital to do that and i just think
that it well
it's disgraceful it's absolutely
shameful it's
what is that the is that the way forward
in this country then we're allowed to
execute children you know because
they've got disabilities what's next
it's just
the hospital says that it's under uh
it's lawful to withdraw treatment but it
that it will do it in consultation with
you have they said anything to you um
well now i had my letter in my letter of
execution details and how it's going to
be mapped out including
multi-talk and things like that just
constant
constant alarm and stress really caused
and even down to the facts that they can
dictate
where my child actually takes his last
breaths
you know
just being obstructive with everything
really it's we haven't even got that
choice can't take him home can't do
anything
it's not right
archie's my child it shouldn't be down
to
other people to decide where he takes
his last breath and if he lives or dies
it's wrong it is wrong and we talk about
this in legal terms a lot we've talked
about all the different court cases but
at the center of this is your child tell
us more about him
actually he was a person he's amazing
he's such a bubbly little boy he's
very energetic he's sensitive he's kind
he's caring
i can honestly say that archer will be
very very disappointed in our justice
system as well most definitely and do
you accept that the courts say that
after extensive hearings they think this
is in his best interest how would they
even know what's in archer's best
interest they never even met him
like come on we've got to be
we've got to be right about this these
people haven't taken their time to come
they've just seen what's on paper the
same as the hospital you know you're a
number you're a case that's it you know
it's it's not let's actually take a look
into this child this is somebody's child
how would i feel i'll put myself in this
mother and father's shoes and this
family's shoes
they're not just taking a child away
from me and paul they're taking they're
just they're destroying a whole family
you know it's not right it's not right
and something needs to be done reform
definitely needs to be taken place in
this country